j'ai décidé parce que vous avez moi je
suis pas perché je dis pas que il suffit
d'avoir une baguette magique et d'exiger
des choses pour qu'elle arrivera pas la
raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé de
convoquer tous les producteurs de
téléréalité
c'est quand cette réunion
la fin de l'année parce que encore une
fois il faut qu'on se pose la question
je veux bien que ça ne passe pas mais il
faut qu'on se pose la question de quelle
société on a envie de voir nos enfants
grandir
je comprends que vous ayez besoin de
commercer parce que finalement c'est
aussi une activité commerciale je
comprends maintenant dans le rôle qui
est le mien je dois veiller à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de stéréotype qui font
perdre la confiance aux jeunes filles
qui vont faire leur faire croire qu'elle
ne peuvent pas faire tel métier qu'elles
doivent faire partie de tel canons de
beauté et qu'il est force à embrasser
des images qui sont complètement
irréaliste donc sans sans forcément moi
c'est c'est pas moi de leur dire ce
qu'il doit faire et comment il doit le
faire que je voudrais c'est leur
expliquer l'impact de téléréalité sur
notre jeunesse et leur dire qu'ils ont
la responsabilité de contribuer est-ce
que nos jeunes grandissent bien et qu'il
ne soit pas mal dans leur peau qui n'est
pas besoin d'un psy à l'âge de 16 ans
parce qu'il pense mérite pas de vivre un
truc influence
influence influence et pour et voilà
pour
elle pour la première fois
donc forcément
aujourd'hui
voilà
moi je pense que votre discours est très
bon je pense que vous avez raison mais
vous tromper de combat il y a deux
choses à voir c'est la télé-réalité les
enfants sœur ces deux mondes différents
la télé
[Musique]
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous voulez
faire
la téléréalité
c'est
vrai vous avez raison
pour moi c'est pas
vraiment
un problème pourquoi parce que il n'y a
pas de réglementation sur les réseaux
sociaux moi ça fait des années que je
demande à voir des rendez-vous avec les
plateformes qui sont responsables de qui
aujourd'hui
intervenu les réseaux sociaux parce que
vous avez mis le nez dedans et parce que
vous l'avez dénoncer vous en tant que
ministre parce que vous avez une voix
qui porte et qui est fort mais si c'est
les autres et que le midi ne regarde pas
personne ne fais rien et ça c'est un
problème avec les réseaux sociaux parce
que justement il n'y a pas de discussion
possible